so we're right okay let's go  paulo okay let's play something decent  on one yeah yeah i mean we have no  guarantees  don't be yeah don't be that optimistic  let's go palm okay  what is six okay this is let's go  let's go was actually against the rules  yes that's exactly what i wanted  let's hope he is uh  fun enough to go e5  yeah let's go pawn continue this yeah  typical  easiest car of my life  [Laughter]  i call your bluff dude  but what if f5 like do we continue  yeah he's in position yeah i mean that's  uh no but i mean okay uh he's on the  button  right now yeah i mean that's what i want  yeah that's what i mean okay let's go up  on whatever  yeah but we can yeah we can uh you know  check race a little  just a little yeah you know v4 actually  has some value maybe yeah i mean it kind  of makes sense yeah i mean okay on one  street we check race and then probably  check fold already  because okay no no i mean now it's over  we won okay